and recruitment you know everyone's
human to the end as they were all people
you know welcome back to another episode
of the recruitment mentors podcast I'm
your host his and on this week's episode
I was joined by a Scotsman in Brian
Fraser average job in a sense is to
networking over talking to people all
day we're talking to clients all day
we're talking to candidates all day who
works for a company called 920
Recruitment and focuses on the marketing
and digital space which he's been
building a market around for the last
five years my grandma who was you know a
keen Gardener not recruiter that
I remember like in a little floral chair
floral carpet and she would say it'll
pass you know and I think that is so
true in life what I love about Brian's
journey is just oozes passion kind of
going straight and then going through
the jugular you know he's developed his
mindset he's huge into building
self-awareness and the overall great guy
who's worked extremely hard to build a
name for himself in this space and
Industry that he increase in we spoke
about community building we spoke about
business development strategies we've
spoken about building a personal brand
to drive business opportunities and so
much more enjoy the episode Ryan welcome
to the podcast thank you for having me
sir excited
thanks for joining me the um the number
of Scottish recruiters that we've had on
this podcast I'll be honest I don't know
why that hasn't been loads I know I
don't know if anyone will think I'm
Scottish with this very strange accent
but yeah a bit of variety for you
now I'm really looking forward to this
so
just to give everyone just some
immediate context uh career highlights
so far where you're on your recruitment
Journey coming up to the five year mark
um in recruitment stayed in the same
organization you started as a candidate
manager in a 180 role in 2018 and since
that point you've sort of gone on this
journey of you know climbing the ranks
where you now find yourself heading up
the digital marketing division for your
organization there's three of you in
that team and it's all perm Recruitment
and you're really doing everything that
you can to build uh the reputation in
the Scottish Market of you know
um being great consulted Recruiters in
the marketing and digital space so I'm
really excited to talk to you today
about you know Business Development
strategies how you've opened up doors
how you've built your brand online
um your journey with leadership and and
much more so where we always like to
start is a million pound question yes so
I'd love to sort of hear your take on
this particularly as you've now you know
hired and added people to your team yes
what what do you believe Brian are the
common characteristics and traits of
successful Recruiters in today's market
let's start there yeah so like you said
million dollar question I think um you
know everyone tends to see a lot of
similar answers and I think um you know
what everyone has said in your podcast
you know previously spot on resilience
you know I think that's a word we use
daily and recruitment you know that's
absolutely bang on and you know things
like having a purpose as well you know I
think we're driven you are the further
it will take you but definitely I could
kind of see
areas that I found that I've had the
most growth in and team members have is
probably having self-awareness and I
think that's something that can really
kind of be built
and you can almost kind of train into
yourself as well and I guess what I mean
by self-awareness if I think back to
when I enter the world of recruitment I
was a bit of a firecracker a bit of a
loose guy and I think and it's almost
kind of beginning to you know think
about that kind of growth mindset and
thinking about you know what are you
saying what are you doing what's going
on in here
what's going on like there as well and I
think that really takes you farm
equipment recruitment's definitely clear
where you climb the ranks so so quickly
and I think with that you need to almost
kind of accelerate your own growth as
well so I think definitely just kind of
having that self-awareness and knowing
the impact of what you do what you say
what you feel and knowing how to almost
analyze that I think and go really far
away and it kind of falls into the whole
kind of growth mindset piece as well
which I think a lot of our us recruiters
are you know quite into and really feed
upon
um no I I love the self-awareness piece
curious then what were some of the
habits that you started to incorporate
in you know your daily life weeks that
helps you build that self-awareness do
you think yes I think it's definitely
sometimes just stopping and thinking
maybe before you talk or before you do
you know
um recruiting such an emotional
career to be in and it can be so
volatile you know things can drop you
know you're dealing with humans
essentially you know that's that that's
a product we've been dealt with so I
think just being able to stop for two
seconds and think before you act it goes
really really far but also there are a
few things that I uh again I've heard
kind of other guests in your podcast
talk ways doing things like journaling
as well you know actually reflecting on
your day so the end of each day I take
just like a minute maybe I reflect on
what I've done been to the gym great but
also what's gone great in work because
again it's quick for us to focus on the
negatives and what went wrong but what
went right you know so definitely just
follow that self-reflection piece
sitting down every night is really
important but also just stopping and
kind of recouping and thinking of what's
going on there it's so important
yeah no yeah I think I really like that
for me uh yeah definitely a big fan of
uh journaling and I really sort of
intentionally make space for myself to
think I think sometimes uh you know
we're either on our phones texting
listen to podcasts listen to music these
things oftentimes we can find ourselves
you know always having external inputs
so habit that I've been definitely don't
do it every single day but I'd say over
the last six months more often than not
I won't go on my phone for the like the
first hour or so and that's been really
helpful you know to uh just have time to
think yeah I think with the content out
there you're totally right there's so
many things to referred nowadays and
even on LinkedIn you know you you have
these kind of entrepreneurs and you know
5vm club and things like that and that's
as much as we'd all love to be like that
you know we're not all built that way
and you know humans are so so complex
and social media and pulse or syndrome
you know so I think definitely switching
off reflecting so so important
so let's get into this then where I
wanted to start is the way that you
describe the Scottish Market to me was
it was like a fishbowl yes yes right and
obviously what I was taking from that is
that it's it's a it's a small Market
yeah right there's there's plenty of
amazing people uh in that part of the
world plenty of amazing thriving
businesses however so what he was
alluding to me was you know you're
always one person away uh you always
speak to someone that's one person away
from knowing who Brian is or you know
someone if you had a if you delivered a
bad experience for someone yeah that
could very easily spread to uh the
people uh that you're looking to you
know support and build a network and
build a community with of course so I
wanted to start with with that in mind
with how you describe the the market
what what have you firstly done to
differentiate yourself because that
means it's even more competitive yeah so
let's start there like over this journey
over the last sort of nearly five years
what have you done you feel to you know
really stand out amongst your peers and
your competitors bearing in mind that
it's a super localized competitive
market absolutely so completely what you
you kind of what you said there you know
it is is a fish bowl and it's so so
small within Scotland compared to say
down in England and other markets like
the US and um kind of word word space
quickly like you said if you if you get
a good experience and as I've kind of
worked through the years you know um
very quickly you hear of other creators
delivered a bad service and typically I
would say where I've kind of heard bad
feedback has perhaps been recruiters not
understanding their Market or
understanding technical requirements and
just just knowing knowing digital
marketing creative within Scotland so
one thing I would say over the years is
definitely just becoming a master of
this Market you're knowing it inside out
so you know if you're recruiting for a
paid social media manager it's very
different from an organic social media
manager knowing the differences knowing
the platforms and going as far to even
playing with those platforms and really
understanding them so I would say really
under standing Market inside out getting
to know the businesses within the market
and you know we talk about Market
mapping that should just be something
you know you have on your computer
you've built out through the years just
through the understanding things very
very deeply and again
understanding and knowing your stuff
then bleeds out to your clients and
candidates you know when I talk to
candidates it's more like I'm speaking
to friends I would say you know we can
talk about marketing we can talk about
you know a g Google analytics for which
is a kind of new update talk about that
talk about AI marketing that type of
thing and again with clients they
understand it
I understand marketing so why would say
this probably differentiating myself
it's just really understanding the
market and I would say I sometimes
almost feel like I work in marketing
than recruiting and marketing if that
makes sense so you know it's not that
I'm just a recruiter I feel like I truly
am a marketing recruiter you know like
almost the marketing comes before so you
just say knowing your stuff building
your credibility goes so so far because
I think people can just see through
I don't know if I can swear but people
can see through BS straight away if you
if you're just trying to be a salesy guy
you know and so yeah a bit of a waffle
there if it doesn't know your stuff
really immerse yourself in it all
so let's just talk about this for a
second so what you're saying there it
sounds like is
like you're not trying to be as
competent as a paid social
um media specialist however what you've
committed to over the years which you
feel like has given you a competitive
Advantage is being really committed to
being curious about what it is that the
people you work with do if that's
playing around the platforms if that's
learning in your own time if it's asking
great questions and then you're sort of
uh I guess showcasing that and talking
about your curiosity and your passion
for the industry uh rather than yeah
just speaking to people about their jobs
their salary uh what they're looking
there next move that's what it sounds
like because I don't want people to feel
like uh you have to become as good as
the people you're placing because I
don't actually believe that to be true
but it sounds like what you're saying is
there you've been really committed to
being curious around your market and
taking a real genuine interest
absolutely and I think
that you know there's so many different
successful creatures out there and I
think you know it's it's such a large
market and there's enough pie for
everyone I think so many people can have
different approaches and have you know
different techniques in the way that
they do recruitment but say that's kind
of what's worked with myself and the way
I I approach recruitment I definitely
just be myself you know be authentic
and I'm generally interested in the
market that I recruiting so I think that
just kind of really bleeds out to the
people that I talk with so from for me
that's definitely something that works
because it shows are incredible and I
know what I'm talking about as well but
as you said all those other things are
really important as well you know you
you you can recruit you know from a job
spec or you really kind of understand
those deep questions you know what is
someone looking for what gets them out
of the bed in the morning you know those
types of things but I would say that's
that's just definitely what's worked for
myself is just really becoming part of
the market and I know
later on we'll kind of discuss the event
that you know I've been hosting and the
fact I'm trying to build a community as
well and I think um over the years it
means that kind of blinds became a go-to
marketing recruiter just because people
tend to know me and the market is small
so you said earlier you used to be a bit
of a loose cannon yeah yeah definitely
what what did that what what does that
what does that look like in the early
days of uh
oh God yeah
um I would say oh God I think I remember
full weekend like highly emotional you
know deals fell through I remember this
one time I think I can't remember the
exactly what happened just a deal fell
through something went Pete Tong you
know it went it went pretty bad and I
remember going in a boardroom and I
think I think I was close to crying and
now I'm like I don't think I would cry
ever you know and I think I think that's
a really good thing about recruitment I
really we use that word resilience all
the time but I think it's a career where
you grow so much like you go if you do
it the right way and you really work
hard I think the growth acceleration is
insane you know and just back then I
would just say I would go into Kohl's
with just clients and then when I when I
look back I'm like oh my God
how was I coming across or with
candidates just just again it was that
piece of not thinking before I'd be
speaking and that's something I'm still
developing every day I still feel like I
do that you know but I definitely would
say I look back nearly five years ago
and I feel like I was like are we 18
year old boy that was just coming into
the community you know like hoping for
the best type thing you know
so okay so I think a lot of people can
relate to you know crying deals dropping
out all that yeah so look let's just
let's just call us back to that moment
for a sec I know I don't you know it
could be quite hard to go back there but
you know with points like there'll be
there'll be people listen to this that
are in that moment right now absolutely
like you know what what is it that you
think you'd you'd say to Brian if he was
in that boardroom yeah he's extremely
emotional you just had some rejection
you'd you know you've had to now you're
gonna have to call a clients and I'm
really sorry they're not accepting your
job offer or whatever it is like what do
you think you'd say to Brian that would
help him hopefully in that moment just
understand or like get through it
basically what is it that you think you
try and get through to Brandon that
moment that would help him come out the
other side sure definitely I kind of
went down this uh kind of Journey of
reading you know self-improvement
because a lot of Attraction so
definitely all of that stuff helps
however going way back in the freezer
family there was actually a phrase my
grandma said to me which is you know and
my grandma who was you know a keen
Gardener nor recruiter soul and she used
to always say I remember like in a
little floral chair floral carpet and
she would say it'll pass you know and I
think that is so true in life you know I
don't know
and life you you got so anxious about
things you know you experience things
like imposter syndrome you know it's
it's really really tough and recruitment
is one of those careers you know it's
it's why we talk about it you know in
the way that we are it's such a such a
tough career and it's just remembering
it will pass like absolutely it will
pass if it's one deal that's a drop in
the ocean if you're looking at your at
your week it's one thing that happened
you're weak if you look in your month
your quarter your year is a drop in the
ocean and it's more about how you
rebound from it you know if you're if
you really get down in the dumps which
absolutely I did you know I cried I
probably pretended I was working on my
computer the rest of the afternoon it
was actually seething underneath you
know I was I was a little bit
um and got no work done and probably
that impact in my whole week whereas now
as a case of you know what
come on like for working together Kansas
we're gonna give a better service you
know just just remember as my grandma
said
it'll pass because I will
great advice I really like that and then
just on this just talking about very
quickly just focusing on for those
listening that might be quite early on
in their careers
[Music]
what is it that you think uh people
listening can uh really focus on
becoming world-class at all really
committing to becoming great at in those
early months that you think could avoid
that could avoid them being in that
boardroom going I've got a drop
out I hate this job I want to
quit is there anything specific looking
back that you think you know what
um if I really just got better at
focusing on that part of the recruitment
process or made sure I asked those sorts
of questions whatever it may be it could
have given me a better chance to having
less of those experience obviously we
can grow from we can learn from yeah
talk to me about that what comes to mind
yes I would say you know that kind of
words before we use a laundry treatment
it's probably there's so many so many
nuances to the role you know there's so
many things that you can always improve
on and I think it is probably that
mindset of always trying to improve and
always trying to be better but one thing
I would say is just really nailing down
processes you know and you know be be
really again I say this and this is
personal personal experience and I do
know there's some amazing recruiters out
there who maybe aren't the most
organized you know and again everyone's
got a different technique so I
definitely would say really you know
nail down on processes because if you if
you have everything nailed down and you
know what you know what is what then
you're always trying to kind of make a
process bulletproof and one thing I
probably would say as well is again that
that's myself seen to be incredibly
organized and find processes to work
that type of thing but that may not work
for the next person but one thing I kind
of wish I had done earlier was probably
just be more authentic and kind of be
myself like I think when I enter the
world of recruitment
kind of hard to think I had to kind of
be the guy going into boardroom in a
shirt you know say the corporate lingo
that that type of thing and that
probably didn't
get me as far as when I finally realized
you know what I'm just going to be
myself and I'm just going to be Brian
and I think when you're being yourself
you're being authentic and you're
comfortable in yourself I just feel like
you Excel much further and I think in
that kind of early days it was a case of
I was having a poster syndrome and I was
trying to impress the next person that
type of thing and worrying about others
worrying about my manager thought with a
deal falling through so I would
definitely just say definitely try and
nail down processes you know do all of
that stuff if that works for you but
just definitely be yourself you know
just try and become that best version of
yourself really and then and just
quickly just to focus on on the how here
so when you say now that process what do
you mean do you think if people
listening were to really double down on
I don't know the candidate qualification
or I don't know what what comes to mind
in terms of what thing can everyone
because there's a there's a lot going on
there's a lot to learn yeah but if you
were to think about that process and I
know not everyone may have a process but
let's be honest you should if you listen
to this you should have some sort of
process you're following
uh what do you think people could should
really become laser focused on that
hopefully you know will they'll thank
themselves for later on the process you
think what do you think they should
really know I think I think it's just
like you said it's it's every single
process every single call that you have
you know you're caught you're constantly
thinking you're thinking prequel you
know pre-qualification you're thinking
pre-closing the person way way before
you're asking what processes are in what
do they what do they need to be jumping
and you know jumping up and down
accepting our offer from you in future
what is going on
um so it literally is every single call
knowing every single bit of information
when it comes to my guys you know that
that's kind of something before we
learned in their Journey where maybe
they've gone into a process and forgot
to ask one question and that can make a
deal fall through and you know it's a
case of you'll learn that for next time
you know
um or you try and grow so it would just
be every piece of the process just
trying to be as precise as you possibly
can you know you should you should
document every if you're a person who
can remember grape you might be a person
who has to write everything down so
write every single piece of information
down because something may trip you up
later on but also one thing as well is
definitely don't pure eggs all in one
basket I would say that is like a
massive thing in recruitment like I
think all the time but like yes we've
bought the golden candy but that's great
but again do we have them you know
what's what's going on in their head
we're not mind readers so definitely
don't put all your eggs in one basket
always think of every case scenario you
know have a plan A B C if you need to
awesome so let's sort of fast forward
this a bit I want to talk uh about uh
Brian going on this journey of you know
becoming a successful 360 recruiter
a lot of people listen to this podcast a
lot of people that are in our industry
right now uh are definitely uh in the
trenches of becoming a successful 360
recruiter are expected
by their employees to bring on more of
their own clients and that oftentimes
can be a really difficult and
challenging period for a lot of
recruiters so let's just sort of you
know hone in uh for a second on that
period where you really had to start
building credibility and Traction in
winning your own clients
um and managing the entire process uh
why don't we just start with you know
what what were some of the early
challenges when you know the expectation
was then put on you on uh bringing more
of your own clients you're no longer can
just sort of rely on the house accounts
the long-standing client relationships
Brian we wanted to be bringing in at
least two new clients per month whatever
those expectations are what were some of
the early challenges when you found
yourself you know on that Journey do you
think yeah I think I think definitely
it's very daunting if you have came from
that 180 background and obviously as we
all know just know the market is
changing we're towards 360 you know and
it's it's just really scary I think
you're always you're always just
thinking rejection you know if you're
picking up a phone or doing an email or
a link to message whatever you know
message you're using you're always
probably scared of the what if you know
you're always um thinking worst case
scenario the thing that I would probably
say when I began going into it is
probably that hesitation and
overthinking it it probably is just kind
of going straight and then going through
the jugular you know
um as I don't hesitate don't don't
second think and think oh what if they
say no the thing is if you if you reach
out to you know
20 prospects and two of them go warm
look at the business that you can
generate from that so I would just
really say just dive in diving head
first but also just kind of be strategic
in the way they are doing it you know
again going back to what you said about
you know
processes and such like again document
everything if you have Market Maps you
know if you you have a candidate in that
area or so for example I work in
e-commerce if I work with one e-commerce
business let's say
and I'm successful recruiting for them
and I'm talking to candidates I'm asking
them where are they interviewing and
then looking at the live vacancies
building a market map building our plan
going to those clients and saying this
is why I've done this is the successes
that I've done you know put my marketing
material their way so I would say that's
a bit around my question but I would say
my my hesitation
my hesitation was just hesitation was
just seconds yeah that kind of little
voice in your head trying over try and
overcome that easier said than done but
it is just a case of the more that you
do something the more that you become
comfortable with it and it's just just
human nature isn't it hey everyone a
real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry and
saucebreaker because you listen to this
podcast you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
let's just think about that for a second
then what were
what were maybe and we can go as
granular as you won like thinking about
that period obviously we're hesitant
because you know are we doing this right
am I gonna sound silly am I going to
come across not credible like am I just
gonna get rejected right I can I can
definitely relate to that it's really
just pushing through that inner voice of
you know saying Brian don't make this
call you could look stupid like you just
have to push through that right and that
is something that if I'm honest you have
to just push through it there's no other
roundabout way really but I guess what I
wanted to ask you was thinking about
that period was there anything that you
found yourself latching on to early on
that you found maybe worked or you know
you had some early success with and
you're like you know what right I'm
gonna keep doing this that's really
working for me you know what what
started what did you find really start
work on those early appears on on the BD
side was it really making sure that okay
I've just placed this candidate let's
really make sure that I maximize that
and say who else do they know what other
hiring managers do they work for that
they really rate which more of the
candidate play was it picking up the
phone and speaking to people they're
hiring and more reactive I don't know
what were some of the sort of early
successes that you think that enable you
to latch on and then build that
confidence because that if you can build
some evidence and you know you can go
you know what I've just done these three
things and it's really worked so you can
then carry that confidence in other
parts of the job so was there anything
that you found early successful that you
latched on to that helped yeah so I'd
say definitely going back to when we
described the Scottish Market it's
definitely definitely a fishbowl where
if you know that you know if you know
one person they will know someone here
etc etc and you you know you find
everyone knows each other so I would say
really really latch onto your network
and that's you know hey that's what we
do as recruiters you know we are our job
in a senses to network you know we're
talking to people all day we're talking
to clients all day we're talking to
candidates all day and really really
latch on to that and look your network
and look at you who you know so it's
it's doing things you know like like
going going to events you know or like
you said if you know a candidate and
you've placed them you know what's the
company that they've came from you know
what colleagues do they have if you are
working with a leader in the business
you know if you're taking them out for a
drink or you're you're meeting them from
you know meeting them up for a meeting
and you're going to be saying you know
who who do you know and just talk talk
talk about the market but definitely in
Scotland it's it's so so small there's
someone tends to know someone
somewhere you know through it there's
always a kind of two degrees of
separation type thing so kind of what I
utilize probably was
um that every kind of Beady opportunity
I saw they could almost
always be a kind of warm lead and that
that's probably kind of what I would say
is that is the best way to be initially
approach BD is try and look for those
warm leads first rather than just going
on going in cold and just jump into the
phone look at look at who do you know
when you're Network you know what how
can you really utilize that Network and
as a career you should you should be
going to events you should be talking to
people and with that if you're doing
that over a period of time if you're
just hitting the phone and talking to
people think of it like a spider web is
just going to keep growing and how can
you really really capitalize on that
Network
what would you define as warm then when
you mention that so for example I would
say um I'll use e-commerce as an example
again it's kind of I guess you could
kind of see like a sub category of
digital um within within Scotland and
you could probably say there are under
40 kind of e-commerce managers within
Scotland they go to a lot of meetups
together and they all tend to know each
other so I I work with this one guy and
I know him really well until very often
talk about an e-commerce manager at this
business and I'll say hey how you doing
do you mind doing a little introduction
for me so you know it's just does this
person know that person are there
meetups happening do they have they
previously worked together again if
you're a market map and did this person
work with that person there again as it
occurred we've come to serial stalkers
don't we in there again
that's the kind of number one piece of
advice I would say as well as always do
your research when you are going to BD
you're talking to new clients whether
you are going to warm like I said or
cold really do your research and know
where they came from know what they've
done but always kind of build out build
out your kind of Market map if you're
going after who's been there and here
and whatever
and uh Curious what have you found to be
the most effective way to get
introductions
um I probably probably recently at the
event I'm running which again I know
we'll be talking about
um I'm finding it's a really good BD
tool because I you know I can go to
people and there's there's not a great
deal of like kind of like marketing
meetups and events within Scotland and
that was
something identified so I can approach
people and there's a few clients very
one via VIA doing that and saying do you
want to be part of our future event do
you want to attend and you're going in
there with another agenda but again
thinking of the long-term game you know
there was there was a client and we
spoke with you know six months ago and
they've just came to me saying we
actually are going to kick off
recruitment now you know so I always
think that kind of long-term game you
know talk to people do introductions let
them know your value your worth what you
can bring to the business but don't
think you need to make money off from
there and then just think of building
the connection in almost kind of
building that business friendship
so why don't we because we can obviously
mention the uh events a couple of times
there why don't we I think a good way to
talk about this would be let's talk
about
obviously right now like in the most
current period I think what would be
really helpful for people is talking uh
getting your perspective on we're
talking about business development here
so I think it'd be really good just to
hear your take on let's just say you
mentioned the spider diagram there if we
were to think about Brian uh Brian's Biz
development uh strategy business Brian's
Business Development approach and we'd
think of a pie chart yeah like let's
break down this pie chart you know what
what makes up this pie chart in terms of
you being successful at BD and building
relationships and getting in front of
people that you know you might be able
to work with now or in the long term
what how would you build up how what
does it what makes up this pie chart you
know so you've mentioned the events
we've spoken about leveraging your
network that you build connections with
and getting referrals yeah how else you
know what else is made up in this in
this uh bead overall BD strategy yeah
definitely so yeah like you said it'd
probably be hard to kind of break a
percentage down exactly if I would just
kind of see with with the event you know
kind of you know leveraging Lansing
who's attending our event who's
interested to community chat to
participate in future sign itself is a
whole kind of BD tool and then just
trying to get introductions from my
network is another big thing as well
we've we've generated a lot of just even
inbound business via that which is
fantastic in that business kind of you
know the more the better but definitely
I would say in in my market you know I
tend to be kind of going after maybe
like ahead of marketing that type of
thing in there wouldn't be like if
you're recruiting in sales they're not
just people sitting by their phone you
know but they definitely are the it's
the type of Market that they are on
LinkedIn a lot you know they're very
active on there you know so it
definitely is about you know I would say
that would be my kind of number one too
would be LinkedIn definitely
um recruiters come in all shapes and
sizes you know and some people like kind
of hitting the phone and picking that up
and doing it that way I definitely would
say I always try and kind of almost Edge
the door open a little bit and then kind
of start going in a bit more heavy I
would say so I would say that would be
my kind of biggest tool but again
as I'm approaching a business on
LinkedIn then they're recruiting for a
couple of roles it's thinking do I know
someone in that business or does that
person know someone there again it's
trying to just show some kind of
relevance or if it's a business that is
a 25 mil e-commerce turnover and go with
them and saying I helped build a team in
a business at similar size from scratch
you know um so I would definitely say
LinkedIn are probably my biggest tool
using the power of my network and again
people I recruited five years ago are
now
and management rules now as well so that
therefore leveraging that thinking that
long term kind of goal as well look at
looking at your network from years back
and thinking as that person became
hiring manager can they get me into HR
and then using the event as well so it
comes through lots of different channels
and I guess I guess when it comes to BD
it's it's definitely thinking of as many
different ways you can bring business on
you know it's not just picking up the
phone or just wanting to messages what
else can you do but can you also attend
events as well so there's great events
are back on though as well amazing great
to be getting out there and seeing
people as well and again just meeting
people in person as well having
conversations you know
um
yeah I think it's thinking of lots of
different Avenues and bringing them all
together no I think that's great for
people to recognize that there isn't
just one single way and if you are just
very reliant on one method one approach
then you're You're vulnerable right
because as soon as that stops working
what else have you got uh in Your
Arsenal and I think what I want everyone
listening to take away here which I
think is really important we've spoken a
lot about mindset you like the way that
you're talking about things is you view
everyone that you connect build
relationships with uh almost under the
same category we could call them
customers we could call them people
whatever but I think where sometimes
people really struggle when they're on
this 360 journey is it's like right nine
to one PM I've got my candidate hat on
and I'm just speaking to candidates yeah
and I'm qualifying and I'm finding out
are they happy do they not like their
manager what Sarah is they're looking
for I'm pitching jobs and then okay two
till five PM Brian I'm gonna be doing my
business development on them maybe even
calling the same people but you know
I've got my advisors on I'm going hey do
you have these challenges at the moment
I've got this candidate you want to
speak to them and I think everything
that you just got discuss that you
haven't you never once or you know
compartmentalized candidates and clients
and I think that's something that people
really should consider is the best
recruiters are speaking to people and
are open-minded to hey let's build a
relationship with this person let's
connect with them and let's gather
information which maybe I could use now
in the short term on the candidate side
of things maybe I could use on the
client side of things but really making
sure that you put everyone under the
same banner and you don't find
yourselves putting on you know your
candidate advisors on and your your
client advisors on so I really
appreciate you uh sharing that let's
talk about specifically the event then
like you've mentioned around LinkedIn
utilizing that I can definitely tell you
know looking your LinkedIn you're
consistently sharing content I think you
um you you know you're building your
your brand I think if someone's to land
on your profile they'd probably have a
better chance of understanding you know
if I speak to Brian or I work at Brian
what that might feel like I think you've
done a really good job of that obviously
the events have been a more recent thing
it'd be really interesting why don't you
uh I think people want to know and I
know you're early on in this journey so
you can sort of be honest with us
how have you how have you you know used
this Channel and vehicle to help on
specifically you know speak to companies
and speak to organizations on the just
to sort of put in a section at the
moment the BD side because I literally
had a phone call today from a Founder
who again bit like you really committed
to building Community wants to give
value
um and they're consistently doing that
but sometimes struggles when to know you
know to flip the conversation or at
least say hey Brian look you know these
mocks and me UPS we do look that's
important to us we want to build a
community but by the way we can help you
find amazing marketing managers you know
like how have you found so far
navigating the look we're not an events
company we're a recruitment company
let's have that conversation though
because that that that's part of the
game so have you found you know
introducing that how have you approached
it so far yeah I would think definitely
um so kind of going back to what I was
saying you know about treating everyone
the same you know in in recruitment you
know everyone's human to the end they
were all people you know so it's kind of
throwing that away and not being
intimidated by people but one thing that
I would say is um when I deal with
clients I'm totally myself you know I've
I've definitely approached everything
with a sense of humor you know maybe
I've not got the best humor you know but
when I'm chatting to people they they
you know I I contend to just be open
with clients and candidates if I'm being
totally honest so you know that
definitely when I so what we're trying
to do just tonight we're a way to go
into our second
um events or a second Meetup now and
we've sold well over 100 tickets so
fantastic that is all great but what
we're looking to do now is we're
building our slate for probably our next
three events so just now I'm speaking to
several businesses agencies and
businesses with the large marketing
departments and I'm speaking to that to
the head of marketing and we're still in
early days you know so we are still in
early days where we're confirming how
they're going to fit into the slots and
the topics and what they're going to
talk about
but when I'm chatting with him I
probably just um real and honest to be
honest and they they know that I'm a
recruiter and when I'm saying my you
kind of my what my proposition is and
what I'm about I'm not a marketeer I am
a recruiter but I really care about the
industry and I really care about the
sector and I'm trying to build a
community because I've seen adapt there
in the Scottish market and there's a
really lack there's a lack of community
there's a lack of togetherness so when
I'm speaking that's a bit of a
long-winded answer sorry but I'm
thinking about probably I'm just pretty
honest I'm like I'm a recruiter and this
is what I do as you said I've got a lot
of it on my LinkedIn there I've got you
know nice kind of sexy pitch decks and
we PDS I can send them just kind of
saying this this is what I do and I'm
really good at it and I'm really
passionate about it and I've tend to
know their business and know what they
do so again I would just say I'm pretty
upfront and I'm not trying to kind of be
about the bushes and but I'm also trying
not to jump on them I would say that's
that's the way I approach things I would
just say talk to people
like their people rather than their
sales targets you know yeah so so
basically what you're saying is in all
these interactions so you speaking to
these people
um the first thing is obviously you're
enabling uh yourself to speak to these
people about your event which maybe you
might not be able to speak to these
people if you're trying to spec in a
candidate have a networking call
whatever right so that's the first thing
but I guess what it sounds like is you
know every time you're having these
calls and interactions you're educating
them on who you are what you do what
you're about so it means that obviously
you're speaking about the event but the
end of each interaction they get off
that call and understand okay well Brian
does that and I know that he does that
as well as trying to you know build a
community for marketers in the Scotland
Market exactly and it's it's a case of
you know their people ask you how your
day is and you know you're you're doing
good things you're doing good
Recruitment and it's it's that case of
you know never never never brag but you
know definitely be be sure of yourself
and know your worth and know that if
you're good
communicate that but you know not not
kind of bragging and boasting but um you
know definitely it's um yeah it is that
piece I would just say of kind of being
authentic and just kind of
being real with him but again it's going
back to that piece I set up a kind of
long-term game as well you know so it
might be that maybe they are a PSL
business and there's so many hurdles to
get through to win them as business you
know I'm not going to win them in two
three four months you know it might not
be until the next financial year you
know so it's not always going into
everything with an agenda as well again
it's that kind of piece of treating
people like people not just thinking of
kind of you know pound dollar signs
above their head you know I I think if I
think a business if you're a good person
and you're authentic in yourself I I do
think that can get you pretty far
um I I think especially with recruiters
it's it's an industry where there can be
you know it can be tarnished with a bad
brush sometimes which is why you know
you're kind of doing what you're doing
and I think if you're just yourself and
you're a good person I think that's such
an a good way to win business as well if
you know your stuff and you're a good
person people recognize that as well you
know and that's what I would say a lot
of my network no I love the clients I
work with clients I worked with back in
2018 still working with today and they
just kind of know me I'm it the chai guy
this speaks a lot of rubbish but we get
on really well working friendship we can
have a laugh you know we can talk about
it weekends you know just be yourself be
a be a good person don't just always
think sales you know but also think
commercial obviously there's business to
run you know yeah of course and then let
just to get um practical on this for a
second as well
like give us some examples how on how
you've used this event or the event that
you're now hosting to you know open up
doors with people that you haven't been
able to speak to before are we you know
how how what does that actually look
like and what does it actually sound
like are you you know reaching out to
Brian and say hey Brian look may have
noticed that we've recently launched
their marketing event reason for that is
this uh would you be against connecting
on uh you know finding out a bit more
thought it could be useful for your team
like how what does this actually look
like you know in practice yeah exactly
so just exactly like you said just
reaching it to people you know whether
that's you know an email a call or a
LinkedIn and just reaching out to people
and typically what I would say when
we're doing each event is um in Scotland
every Market here regardless of the
level is aware that there are a lack of
events you know um in Scotland in the
Tech Community for example yeah it is
really cool monthly meetups are
happening they talk Tech they have pizza
that's a thing it's not really been a
thing in marketing so already when I
approach people it's it's almost just
extending a hand and kind of extending
and inviting to be really awesome to
have have you the next event you know
we're trying to bring together lots of
like-minded individuals and bring
together you know the best talent in
Scotland you know into our room you know
so it's almost kind of extending a hand
and kind of giving them something kind
of scratching their back because chances
are if they're really into their sector
and they're passionate they'll identify
there is a lack of this networking a
lack of these events and typically
people will come back and they they will
say it and you know really really admire
what you're doing it's great to see
someone's really taking the lead taking
the charge trying to build something so
it's really just reaching out with that
kind of
and kind of saying it'd be great to have
you along and there's been several
clients I've done that with that came to
the event or they're coming to future
events or they're going to speak a
future events and we're we're having
coffees and we're talking about business
and talk about what I do again I'm not
selling what I do but I'm just telling
them what I do and I am credible and I'm
I am good at what I do you know and
again that's kind of it's that kind of
thing and again why you know personal
brand on LinkedIn it's something I
definitely know I can be better with you
know you're obviously a wiz you know
when it comes to that but you know it's
that whole thing of them being the first
person that they think of when they
think Recruitment
and what have been some of your uh
biggest wins so far
yeah so as in kind of client-wise for
the events what would you say is like
you know let's talk you know let's talk
commercials people may think events have
already been done you've obviously
recognized an opportunity which I think
is awesome you've taken action I'm sure
there's people you know sitting in your
Market going oh I've I've had that idea
but you know you've taken action so give
us you know give us a bit of a snapshot
of one of the wins that you've had maybe
you met a candidate that you ended up
placing or you know recruiting I know
right is this you know is this impacting
the the targets that we're trying to hit
you know yeah 100 so we we had one
client we're gonna get involved in the E
future
um event
um our kind of social media orientated
um agency and
um we reached out to them about speaking
our future event met up for a coffee
lovely guy he's building a business up
and he's a way to go through a lot of
growth working some really cool Brands
like Skyscanner and um I want him as a
client just because he was pretty
transparent it's just like I spoke into
a lot of recruiters and I've just had
terms and documentation throwing me
whereas we've met up we've chatter where
the market bastard beans together and
you know with the same Vibe I can tell
you you really care you know yourself so
one that uh just now I'm in
conversations with a massive um media
agency they're up and down the UK
several offices so again that could be
something really major in there and
they've managed to organically grow
their team within Scotland but they're
await again to kind of go through the
hyper goal phase and really really scale
at some rate which they just wouldn't be
able to do organically in future so
again
um the MD of that business is going to
speak on a future event and um we'll be
looking to hopefully partner with them
in future as well and it was also
another e-commerce business where it
kind of reached out about them attending
our event they are in a very obscure
location so that was inviting for them
and they weren't able to attend but open
up a conversation and again we met for a
coffee had a good chinwag and I've got a
ton of interviews booked in with them
this week you know it's it's just about
chatting you know just just having
conversations with people with it's
almost I always say it's trying to kind
of Creak that door open a little bit you
know just slightly get it open and just
go in and be yourself
you mentioned their uh terms obviously
we're really focused on this BD topic
here but I know this is what people need
help with Brian I'm sure you know I know
the two people in your team are
hopefully going on that Journey at some
point on the 360 side right how have you
approached negotiating fees with clients
because I think that's also something
that can be daunting at the beginning
you know yeah the first I always
remember my you know first sort of pitch
around these are my terms this is why
I'm selling hard I still like why it's
20 and these things like you know like
why don't we why don't we let me ask it
this way yeah what did uh what did it
sound like or look like when Brian was
pitching terms and fees and percentages
um in the past when maybe you know
there's room for improvement and then we
can talk about how sort of it looks like
now and how you've improved it like what
did it sound like that you think you
know what wasn't that great but you know
I was starting out I was learning what
did it used to sound like when you were
negotiating fees and objection handling
how do you approach pitching your
service and your fears yeah 100 so way
back when it was baby Brian who was you
know having a cry a cry here and there
and it definitely was trying to probably
go in too early with that you know and
always it probably was thinking I would
kind of go to clients like all terms are
usually around this level you know
you're you're I think as a recruiter you
sometimes kind of undervalue yourself
sometimes and you kind of say you're not
terms are not only around us and you
know if your terms of whatever
percentage you're going with that
percentage which is just like you know
the opposite of negotiation you just
kind of go in and I don't know if this
is a bit of a crude phrase but you kind
of drop your pants don't you because
you're just you're you're earlier in
your journey you're trying to impress do
the right thing as you get further on
and you kind of you know yourself more
you know your Market more and you know
you're you're good at what you do I
probably go in with the terms that the
very very end to be honest you know it
probably is one of the very last
questions that they ask um and before
I'm even and then with that those terms
that that percentage or you know
whatever it may be and they they know
what you know they know what I can do
what businesses I worked with you know
again it's about building that online
brand am I LinkedIn I think I've got
like nearly 60 recommendations all
relevant to the market that I work in
things like that and I've got really
nice kind of we pitch decks I've had my
marketing guys create that type of thing
so they already know what I can do and
they probably know from the
conversations or you know like I said I
always try and meet my clients for a
coffee
you probably know that I can achieve and
I can add value again is that if you're
talking with a client you're you're
listening to them and you're identifying
their problems and then you're adapting
your your pitch to basically say you can
fix those problems and then when you've
got them Who client and sink are then
going with the terms and again be cheeky
put a couple of percentage of this to
what normally your organization does
that type of thing you know and
you know in a few maybe after drop out a
week but you can but it's not going to
be below but it should be you know so so
definitely um sell your worth sell your
value and think term to the very end
because I think it's something you get
scared with you think of terms and
signing a contract and stuff and really
it's a tiny piece of the whole process
it's
you know all right I've got some
questions on this yeah because I think
this would be really helpful for people
so yeah just quickly first one I want to
speak about this pitch deck because I
think this is something I've been
speaking to quite a few recruiters about
is something that I've implemented in my
own sales process and it's been a real
game changer but the first thing I just
wanted to ask you because I'm sure you
might run into this maybe with your team
when you all talk some about you know
doing BD terms all that is they might go
Brian
how can I speak to him about fees and
terms at the end when it's the first
thing they ask me
what's your response to that you know
because you know you've got your process
you want to showcase your credibility
you're like no no let me show you my
value let me show you what I'm about and
they're like Brian look we can only get
this signed off we can only do 18 so
what what are your percentages like how
does this work how how have you have you
navigated that because that's tough
right yeah I know absolutely and
probably I always kind of try and think
I always kind of try and Pitch before
I've even had that first call so you've
obviously got your actual proposal
document we've tried to kind of make
ours a little bit sexier and we've got
uh awesome graphic design it's done a
great job on that so we have that which
of course I have had initial
conversation but I even just have a kind
of re-document that has all my
testimonials and even I link people to
my LinkedIn say you know there's all
those recommendations there so chances
are they've already kind of done a
restock with me and they kind of know
what I'm capable with so I'm always
trying to kind of think push credibility
prove that we can do the job before we
even have in that conversation if the
clients ask about it just go in and just
just be sure just be sure of yourself
trying you know if that voice is in your
hand Edge and you're trying to kind of
go in and drop your pants just try and
say no just say no to that voice and
just go in and just like that this is
our terms this is what we do but this is
the value that we can add and then if
they obviously talk about you know
negotiating terms you know we could we
can say that's something we can discuss
you know later we can discuss it later
but let's let's have the conversation
first before we before we do that before
we press signature in the daunted line
so I would always say
I try and maybe start around that a
little bit and build that relationship
and build that credibility before doing
that so I know that's kind of like a
roundabout about it
no you've answered by saying hey look if
you're in that position yeah sometimes
you know you have to own it and be like
okay look this person needs to know and
I've been there and I think the advice
is own it you know don't you know say
like look so absolutely I can explain
those for you so uh if this is
contingent then we'll be working on 20
um uh rate 20 of the uh salary
um that's how we work these are our
terms and then be quiet don't say
anything you know don't keep babbling on
like trying to justify it
um like just own it and be sure like you
said I think that that's the advice but
let me let me just come back to the the
pitch deck because I think this would be
really interesting for people if you
don't mind
of course so just for context then
so when would you be introducing this
pitch deck for example because you
mentioned quite a few facets there so
I'm assuming that I don't know maybe
we've had a bit of an initial
conversation Brian and it made sense
that we're booking a call maybe a video
maybe in person where we're going to
talk about you potentially helping my
organization or us partnering so I'm
assuming this has been some sort of
dialogue some sort of connect and chat
before we've then booked in time to chat
and this is in this chat
um we're then gonna I don't know we
might then have this chat and then we do
the pitch deck I don't know you tell me
the typical process but I want to know
when you typically introduce this pitch
deck and use those assets to you know
demonstrate value demonstrate case
studies uh testimonials and Then
followed by and these are our terms and
how we work together when do you
introduce that what's the process yeah
so we've kind of gone we're like
in-depth pitch deck which is the in the
one where they're gonna have to go away
and proper read everything and we do we
do have a kind of smaller little it's
more of a kind of like two-pager PDF and
that base case where it's hyper and like
our LinkedIn or our contact details and
that is client testimonials and candida
ones and they tend to cover the market
and sometimes they even have one that's
more geared towards e-commerce ones
geared more towards PPC SEO that type of
thing so if I if say I'm I'm trying to
go after you know after a perspective
client you know via um via just LinkedIn
or email and that like little mini pitch
deck I've created yeah you might attach
it there okay yeah I actually just fired
it on straight away and I've actually
got a meeting with a guy next week and
it literally was that was it was a cold
LinkedIn I saw it's always been going
through some really nice growth and
we've got a chat and a chat next week
and the testimonials I send over I got
my designer to edit some bits and it
basically was businesses like identical
to his business
and he's gonna go yeah yeah like that
that guy can clearly recruit for my
business and he's yeah I could see view
my LinkedIn profile so I'd probably be a
wee bit bold and already put that over
straight away but again you know we're
the crews and I think I'm more in tune
with this because I recruit in marketing
but also think as well you're having to
Market it yourself so everything you do
you know you're you're copywriting your
your your material all of that needs to
be top-notch because otherwise an extra
career is gonna have do it better than
you earning yeah okay no I really like
that thank you for sharing that so so
I'm just going to pressure a bit here so
we've got the two-page a bit more high
level yeah what I want everyone to
underline here right we've done some
trending on this recruitment mentors
yeah and Sony recruiters don't use
testimonials and case studies they don't
they don't so many don't yeah so what
Brian is talking about here is Brian
isn't doing the talking his track
recorders so for all of you that aren't
utilizing your testimonial LinkedIn
testimonials case studies in your sales
process when you're reaching out to
people start because you'll stand out
and all of a sudden it isn't Brian the
recruiter sound like everyone else
saying hey give me a chance look I used
to speak to me this is the reason it's
like hey look just so you know it's like
you've gone on this growth Journey we've
actually helped companies similar to
yours this is what their experience was
like would you be uh again it's booking
in a conversation to see if it would
make sense for us to get to know each
other a bit more right so that's done
the talking so I guess all I want to
know is let's say then we have the chat
so that conversation you've had in
are you when when do when do you use the
more in-depth uh pitch deck out of
Interest yeah so chances are if you know
I've either called hold him or I've done
LinkedIn at an email and we've had that
that initial conversation is about
getting to know we're another it's a
chemistry call essentially isn't it you
know um and you know I'm finding out
what their issues are listening to them
you know what's what's their Growing
Pains you know what are they going
through what's their problems right now
is there is a recruitment supplier not
hitting the mark that type of thing
listening to it and then looking at how
we can solve that and then adjusting
your pitch accordingly and then after
that would tend to be when we would send
over them we're in-depth uh kind of
proposal document and then if they're
happy with that do the terms you know
digital sign that type of thing but
typically I would say
um and again I I think it's because I
always tend to have quite natural
conversations with kind of prospective
clients probably after that first call
probably by the time the Call's over you
probably know if you want to work with
one another or not and again it's about
trying to kind of build build that
familiarity building that relationship
up and again I think it is just by being
natural yourself I really like that
chemical I like the way yeah because
like what in my sales process I would
have a discovery call that's what I
would call it and then what I would do I
know it's different but I would then if
it makes sense to I would then be like
okay Brian look from what I've learned
today I feel like we could actually
potentially help your business these are
the reasons why
um would you be against giving me
another hour of your time 45 minutes
however
um and I'm gonna walk you through how I
believe we can help you
um and why we could potentially you know
be a good partner for you so it sounds
like then after that chemistry call are
you then sending over the pitch that you
don't book in time to go through it it
depends on buying signals you know and
it it depends how they're you know how
they're feeling and there's a lot I've
had a lot of those conversations before
and straight away you can tell they're
Keen you can tell they're sword and
that's it and you're happy to go and
you're ready you're thinking right we're
going to do a site visit we're going to
onboard that it was fantastic that's for
you and sometimes client may say they
want to go away and you know think about
I I had a chemistry call with with a
client the other week and it went pretty
well but um he hadn't worked with
recruiters before because they had
always kind of recruited organically so
what I then did was I went on site and
we had a conversation and from there
it's it's just kind of reading the room
again we're dealing with humans
everyone's very different you know some
people will will put up a shield and
they'll kind of have you know kind of
keep recruiters at arm's length and you
have to try and break through that
Shield so again it's just kind of
reading the room I I suppose and again
that's kind of not a straight up answer
but I think it is just a recruitment you
need to be you need to adapt so much and
I don't think you can do a kind of one
size fits-all approach as I said
sometimes you know if someone's Keen
again if you speak I can't do you know
if they want to go for the job or not or
they might want to go away and think so
again what can you do and
they're not on board and you don't think
you know you're going to be working with
them the next day and be going to that
next stage then say it right well you
know let's let's be up and let's let's
have a coffee you know and you can do
some more more research I can I can send
over the proposal document again our
proposal document is very soft it's more
about kind of what we do it's more about
how we Market rules it's more about what
we have done it's less about terms and
it's less about the corporate stuff it's
it's a nice kind of user-friendly
document you know so again
just read the room and kind of that
that's just the number one thing is you
just you just need to adapt to every
single individual you're dealing with in
recruitment it's just you could you can
all use the same principle for every
client and every person
uh is there anything that you've
recently you know adapted added change
to your sales process that you think's
had a real positive impact recently yeah
so I probably would see it was
um it probably was kind of adding that
first initial document definitely like
that was a really good idea like that
that definitely helped and the way I
think about it is safe you know not
saying I'm an athlete or something say
If You're an athlete and you're a bit of
what you did chances are you've got your
trophies in a cabinet and I think your
careers kind of need to think like that
a bit more you know if you if you've
held that business skill you've done
this you've done all those achievements
and that's why you should have all the
recommendations you should have that on
a Wii proposal document you know I I
think you should definitely again it's
that fine line between boasting and
kind of being being aware and showcasing
your achievements you know so definitely
that and the the number one thing I
would say as well maybe not so obviously
probably more kind of last six months is
definitely trying to do the face-to-face
meetings 100 I think I feel like a lot
of my clients are still adapting to you
know doing face-to-face meetings they're
used to just jumping on teams but again
it's so important to build that
chemistry and again just just go for a
coffee go grab wheat Starbucks and get
to know them as a person and build build
our friendships
I love it I know we've gotten super
Granite here on BD but honestly I know I
know I know honestly Brian there's so
many sort of nuggets in there and I know
there's so many things that people can
take away and that that's what it is
people want to listen to this sort of
stuff and you know be able to apply
stuff so for me if I'm listening right
now and I haven't got any sort of you
know sales assets or sales collateral
that would be the number one thing I'd
be going hey right yeah my manager can
you help me create this this is
something that I need it's going to help
me and like you said it isn't about
boasting it's about having other people
give you credibility and sort of vouch
for you know what you're saying to
people and let's be honest like for me
this is how I find it as well is when
you have these things created and you
can see them in front of you these you
know case studies or testimonials it
gives you more confidence
it makes you more share of yourself sure
of yourself right this is what it's
about like you know like um yeah like
you you can outwork yourself down you
can create more evidence to back up why
you shouldn't doubt yourself like you
know and and that's something you should
absolutely be utilizing as a recruiter
particularly as things get more tighter
budgets potentially get more tighter
it's like look you need to be sure of
yourself and use your track record and
what you've worked hard to do to do the
speaking for you
um so uh look I think what you've spoken
a lot about in this episode is owning
who you are being yourself so you know
what what advice would you have for
people that are struggling to walk into
their power and and be themselves and
you know uh or I find that difficult
because not it's easy to sort of hear
you say yeah look be yourself
how what you know what would be your
advice to someone listening to this you
know find that difficult they feel like
they have to have that worse work mask
on yeah what advice would you give to
them to you know lean into that power
and own who they are which actually is
gonna uh you know be the the best thing
they can do for their career yeah
definitely it's it's a journey for sure
like way back when I was at school I was
like I was like the bullied little gay
nerd basically like when I was a skill
so it's taken probably for me
recruitment probably has enabled me to
become that confident person and you
know to become sure of myself
um so for that I'm so grateful to the
equipment in the business I work for you
know because I've been able to really
grow and kind of flower as a person
because I was like I said I said
different pie in way back but probably
would say it would be the people you
surround yourself with and the leaders
in your business in the business that
you are working for
um you know the the business that I work
in we were always more of a standard
recruiter you know so they were always
doing kind of tech you know kind of Dev
type stuff and Engineering manufacturing
and my um directors they they've let me
grow a division and they've honestly
just kind of let me go and do my own
thing and have completely empowered me
and kind of offered me that support to
do that you know where a way to kind of
do a bit of a brand relaunch where it
could be nine-to-fight marketing and
digital and really go hard after that so
why would probably say is and this is
probably an extreme thing to say but
probably just make sure you're in the
right business and you're surrounded by
the right people because I've worked
with a lot of people who maybe worked in
quite corporate environments and they
were incorporate I know if if I was in a
corporate recruitment business right now
where it was like kpis that I've been
all flourish I would have not done well
at all so I would say just think about
think about where you are do you have
the right influences around you it's
that whole
thing isn't it of you know you surround
yourself you know your result of The
Five People You surround yourself with
type thing you know so make sure you're
really in tune with that and think about
how you can flourish and who's actually
gonna you know who's gonna lead you and
who's gonna grow you great advice Brian
thank you so much no thank you so much
like I said I waffle a lot but I'll play
some good nuggets there from there
absolutely Scotsman yeah thank you so
much for listening to the episode I hope
you enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode
all right